we do have Sam shankland with us Sam I
have to ask you about this moment you
had a golden opportunity at move
five you could have taken on B2 take us
through that moment did you realize that
you could have taken on B2 what's your
reaction unless is that not just a draw
after Knight B5 or what did I miss was
knight5 Knight
D4 oh that's the one isn't
it I don't know then so yeah I guess I
just missed a winin one move I thought
this was just Theory and that I was
supposed if that Queen V2 is always a
draw after Knight B5 and I wanted to
play but apparently this just wins in
one move and I'm too stupid to see it is
that what you're telling me not a stupid
part don't put words in my mouth look
you trusted Andrew in that moment and
you played G6 but yes Queen takes B2
wins on the
spot after five moves okay you should
just kick both of us out of the
tournament then I mean that's really bad
but you did play G6 you still had a good
position take us through the remainder
of the game after that did you feel at
any point you were on the brink of a
victory yeah I think Andrew just played
really terribly until he needed to find
only moves and then he found them all uh
was my sense so for example the most
critical Mo the first critical moment
was after I played Knight D5 um so yeah
there it came Knight D5 and then I
thought Bishop C4 was is very stupid and
he should play Knight B3 instead uh
because here I think he's just worse
after H6 after Knight B3 I was thinking
H6 and Bishop D2 it's probably about
equal or so but after Bishop C4 y yeah I
couldn't find anything great there after
Bishop C4 H6 I thought this was just
fantastic for black after Bishop D5 hg5
and here the question was should I have
played D5 or not because G4 was also
possible and after G4 I thought he can
go D5 himself Bishop takes B5 Bishop
takes B5 and don't know maybe I'm
slightly better here but I wasn't super
convinced for example Knight F6 F G4
Knight D5 and Knight C4 and I didn't
think this was anything too special um
maybe I'm slightly better I don't know
no you're right uh so I played D5 and E5
and I think here if Andrew doesn't do
exactly what he did he's going to be in
huge trouble uh but he defended it very
well with Knight
B3 and yeah I think Knight B3 was the
only way and then I underestimated this
Knight B Tak 64 and somehow here he's
he's getting away and he should be
holding pretty easily then the next
critical moment came when he played F
takes G4 which I think was a very bad
move um here uh if he does like anything
else I think like just Rook A8 first and
then fg4 or or Knight E6 and fg4 it
should just be dead draw like I don't
really think there's anything to be said
but after he played F G4 here and I can
take on A1 and then play Knight takes D4
and Rook C4 I have everything to to play
for and then the only question is if I
ever had something in this Rook end game
it's very very close but I did not see a
clean win so and there was no clean win
actually he defended accurately all the
way until the end after so yeah and just
yeah because after B5 Rook C6 yeah I
covered I just came out with theoretical
Rook end games and I covered a very
similar position to the one we ended up
getting so yeah Rook H2 a rook B5 and I
believe my only chance I cannot possibly
throw my pawns my only chance should be
to try to um my king with the B Pawn and
take it and what it comes down to later
if we go to like the spot where he got
the where I played Rook takes B7 let's
say um yeah so here and then around here
up to here like if uh so Rook F4 is only
move of course if my Rook gets to F5 the
game is immediately over um and after
Rook F4 could I have played Rook B5
check the computer says apparently I'm
curious I King to
G4 so hang how does King F6 lose king6
just uh King to B7 only move by the way
and rook and Rook F1 what's the point I
couldn't figure out what to do Rook F1
King to C6 now and I guess you just go
to D and then Rook F2 and he just sits
what's the point now you go to
D7 okay oh I see and then King E8 and
yeah I see and he can never go Rook E2
so then I definitely should haveed yes
yeah then I definitely should have
played Rook B5 uh Rook B5 check because
if you give the position after 51 King
G4 the computer says this is a draw but
there's only going to be one Fortress so
F5 check yeah so F5 check I play after
King G4 and then King G5 Rook B6 and now
the only Fortress that works for white
which is actually quite hard to find is
he needs to set up with King F4 and Rook
G2 or else he will lose so for example
here let's say I go King C7 mhm and I
start to bring my king towards the
center sure there and then Rook D6 I
have a very basic plan I will run my
king King all the way to like let's yeah
so here he his only drawing move is to
play drawing IDE is to play King F4 King
D7 is the wrong attempt to win I should
play King C6 and well here he doesn't
need it but I should play King C6 I
should play King C6 instead of uh King
D7 this is most testing mhm uh and here
let's say Rook G1 or whatever and then
uh I go like King D5 he's going to need
to find King F4 sooner or later because
like basically my if I can ever get my
King to like some more sensible say D2
yes if I ever get my king to D2 with his
King on G5 Rook D King E2 Rook D3 and I
will win the game with the F Pawn okay
so the goal should be for black should
be to bring the king to D2 and The Rook
to D3 and then King to F2 and then black
wins with he will lose the G pawn and
the F Pawn will go yeah so like let's
say King C5 Rook G2 if he's yeah so King
C3 and now yeah let's say like here King
E2 and now he's dead yes so uh it's and
it's too late for that but if he had
played King F4 earlier then white is
making a draw because after uh because
he'll have too many checks and it's
annoying so for example yeah here King
F4 my king will not be able to make it
where it needs to go um yeah
so yeah uh get this I should have done
this because it would have at least
asked him to find this plan but it is
still a draw yeah yeah no very tense
game uh big opportunity but still this
is only round one how did you get ready
for this tournament Sam because we know
you need your energy levels for such AOS
and such a long event yeah mostly I did
a fair amount of physical work and just
tried to get a lot of sleep I have F
Grand right after this as well so that's
what 22 games in 30 days so I have a lot
of games to play and uh well I mean I
did normal opening work and stuff but I
really tried to prioritize rest and uh
just staying in a good mood and staying
happy and healthy that's usually the way
to do it well Sam we'll see you
tomorrow yeah thank you
thank you uh Sam and Kate uh take us uh
through the results and let's